-Joining me now is the star
of "Brooklyn Nine-Nine,"
which airs Thursday nights
on NBC.
Here's the one, the only,
Andy Samberg!
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-Andy!
Oh, my goodness!
Ah! Look at you, wow!
Looking good, bud.
How are ya?
-I'm good. How are you?
-I'm great.
I miss you, man.
I'm so happy that you're here
on the show.
I wanted to play
a fun game with you
because I know
you're a great songwriter
and I'm assuming
that you probably know a lot
about famous songs,
so I want to put
[ Laughter ]
your music knowledge to the test
in a game called
"Misname That Song."
Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪ Misname that song ♪
♪ Misname that ♪
♪ Song ♪
-[ Laughing ]
Now, Andy,
in front of each of us are
the incorrect names
of a number of famous songs.
All of these names are close
to the actual name of the song,
but not quite right.
When it's your turn,
you'll read out
the messed up version
of that song title,
then, the other person tries
to guess the correct song title,
based on only that clue.
We have to guess
as many songs as possible
before the timer runs out.
Are you ready for this?
-I couldn't be more ready.
-Yeah.
-I was born for this.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, I know you were, yeah.
Well Andy,
since you are my guest,
you're going to guess
first, okay?
Let's put 45 seconds
on the clock.
We got this, buddy.
And here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-"Driver's License."
-That's correct.
[ Ding ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-"Goodbye Thrice?"
-"Goodbye Thrice"
is not the song, nope.
-"Bye, Bye, Bye."
-Yes, that's correct.
[ Ding ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-"I exist on a vessel
that floats in water"?
[ Laughter ]
-You should really --
-"I'm on a Boat"?
-Yes, "I'm on a Boat"!
[ Ding ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's by you!
You wrote that!
Okay.
[ Buzzer ]
Ugh!
Alright.
Not bad.
-Excuse me.
-Three.
Three is the magic number.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah.
Sorry.
A little rusty in there.
I was a little rusty,
there, Andy.
It is now my turn.
[ Laughter ]
Let's put another 45 seconds
on the clock.
-Okay.
-Whenever you're ready,
go ahead and read
the misnamed song title.
Here we go.
-You ready?
-Yeah, I'm so ready.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
-Okay.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-"Dancing Queen."
[ Ding ]
[ Cheering
and applause ]
♪♪
-"Large fruit --"
"Watermelon Sugar"!
"Watermelon Sugar."
[ Ding ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
"You and I have shared --"
Us, brothers and sister --
[ Laughter ]
Family --
"We are Family"?!
[ Ding ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Sister Sledge.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Naked --
[ Buzzer ]
-Ooh! [ Laughs ]
I got the finger wag.
[ Laughter ]
-"No Scrubs," Jimmy.
-Oh!
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about.
"No Scrubs"!
-"No Scrubs."
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, it is a tie, bud.
-Tough crowd.
-Look at this.
It's a tie, 3-3.
-It's a heated war!
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, but we're not
about fighting.
We're about loving.
-Sure.
[ Laughter ]
For this last round,
we're going to see
how many songs we can name
together, okay, okay?
-Okay.
-So we're going to take turns
reading the titles and guessing.
I'll start us off
by reading the first clue.
Then, you read the next one.
And I think our record
on this is four?
So, if we beat four.
-Do you remember
who it was with?
-I think it was Pink.
-Oh, we've got to beat Pink.
[ Laughter ]
-We love Pink, but yes.
-Yeah, no, we love Pink,
but we got to beat her.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's right.
The audience is with us!
[ Applause ]
Alright, here we go.
On your mark.
Get set.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
I'll go first.
♪♪
-"Papa's Got a Brand New Bag."
[ Ding ]
-Absolutely.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Okay.
♪♪
-I have no idea what that means.
[ Laughter ]
What's the fourth planet
from the Sun? Is --
"Life on Mars"!
"Is there life on Mars?"
[ Ding ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Fresh laughter ]
-Conceived in order
to move my legs fast"?
-That's correct.
-"Born to Run"?
-Yes!
[ Ding ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-"Bennie and the Je--."
[ Laughing ]
[ Ding ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
Oh, my gosh.
[ Buzzer ]
♪♪
-I celebrated too much.
I should've said the last one,
which you would've gotten,
which was
"Violet precipitation."
-"Purple Rain."
-Of course. We would've had it.
[ Dinging ]
We tied Pink.
-We could've beat Pink, dude.
-Yeah, we could've,
but didn't do it
because you know what?
-A tie is good. A tie is good.
-A tie is good. We're not
about winning and losing.
We're about loving.
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly!
-Andy Samberg, everybody.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about.